a sea of people
amidst the corona virus pandemic
hundreds and thousands of migrants
desperate to reach their homes in rural
India they converged at a bus terminal
in Delhi as the state of Uttar Pradesh
sealed its borders the police force
overwhelmed by the crowds the surge of
people forced the government to arrange
thousands of buses to take them back
home men women and children have walked
for many miles crossing state after
state in a lockdown but it's only here
to attack on everything
I mean Bengal barium there is no social
distancing or protection for these poor
daily wage earners and contract workers
this informal sector forms almost 80 of
India's workforce the government failed
to factor in such a rush while locking
the country for 21 days giving just four
hours of advance notice police have
beaten seized vehicles and even
threatened jail sentences for those
define the restrictions here in Delhi
the national capital the borders have
been sealed and police have put up
barricades checking everyone's identity
cards only those involved in essential
services are allowed to be on the road
Chris Paula and Mandy from Derbyshire
are caught in the lockdown on their
dream holiday having spent a night on
the streets they are urging the
government to help them get back home to
the UK we've been totally abandoned
I mean it's laughable we do feel that
people are I mean they're sympathetic
but it's just like what on earth is your
government doing for you just like
nothing in a country where medical
facilities are inadequate and social
distancing measures are clearly being
ignored
- desperate attempts to escape the virus
has a potential to spread like wildfire
here India needs urgent intervention
never Lazarus Sky News Delhi